[Music]
okay so this video is where the keeps
even attached now this is key musubi
means nothing at key so why I like to do
this money it's going exclusively a
distance around the close-up where the
attacker and the defender both trying to
feel movement from the other side I was
going to do our clothes more on closer
person that I do before more like the
the old style part the practices that we
did on the previous video okay so I'm
talking to her first and then we just
doing it's kind of intense to the funny
it's all the way okay so good this
distance now this is various ways of
getting into this so we start here we
both move back together now how I
further do I mean you can do you're both
insane move on the spot which is easier
to say this it's loading keep this the
same doesn't mean mother but I like the
attacker to step forward and the
defendant step back it just feels more
consistent with the the practice and
also if you're doing in it's a new this
is the gradient you
who's basically supposed to be attacking
which is always a good tip under a
pressure situation so we go to somebody
first burry he said all I said but he
then he cut through maintain this
distance here so I stepped inside should
be time but because I'm talking I'm just
going to go through the motions if he
then goes strike I for up see she kind
of feel where he's in stopping I step to
the side as that block goes and cuts and
I cut down again we should be together
at this point he then goes for strike I
say control in the center back okay kind
of feel it between you they requires a
lot of concentration I say if you can do
so fast and more Indian more closely
look at the the other part practices and
they're the best place to do that so you
can't learn that from the old part
practices and then you move into this
more flowing type exercise
okay so that should be done with a a
single breath KC breathe in as you take
the soil up into the first very slight
boom you do that i'm intrusively and the
rest is done with one continuous breath
[Music]
okay so that's the chemical attacks it's
like a key by the exercise rather than
more dynamic our practices should be a
little bit different otherwise McKee if
you do the same if he becomes the same
yeah it feels a bit more dynamically
girls do stuff on the human touch is
also going to be doing slightly
different sword works slightly out
slightly one style is future video so
carefully
[Music]
you